yeah persistence take me out
does he need to pay
yeah yeah
that's the minimum
what percent of the time are you talking
about like once you're dating should he
pay 100 of the time the first time the
first day you should 100 definitely pay
and then after that i will like you know
offer to pay but you don't you don't
really want you still meant to say no
it's fine i got this but you know i will
i hold my own so i will you know offer
to pay okay but like you're kind of
would you be annoyed if if he said okay
yeah go ahead
i'll get up and we'll go ahead
i'll just pay and then i'll just be like
all right now i see you i see
and will you not see him after that or
would you still see him i'll probably
give him one more chance if he does it
just like this or is it cooked yeah
um for me
just be like respect loyalty
you know
yeah stuff like that okay do you want me
to answer for a guy or for a girl oh
shoot no we're gonna do guys next
um i want you to be obsessed with me to
be honest yes like i want you to text me
call me all the time but then don't be
too much
not overbearing so i have a question um
is there someone you think of like the
guy you loved the most like one guy that
comes to mind yeah did was he obsessed
with you yeah okay usually i find that
it's not the same like usually it's like
the guy that the girl likes the most
like isn't obsessed with them at all
really yeah yeah
nah i i feel like
like texting you daily
nice dates not like your type of yeah
but like i i want i want the minimum
conversation maybe or maybe minimal
standard like oh good morning have a
good night kind of thing okay it doesn't
have to be a full-on conversation all
the time but show me that you're
interested what about dates
should he pay 100 of the time um
i mean if they're trying to court me
like they quoted all the ladies back in
the day
you should be paying no like
all of this is not free
but then obviously as things like evolve
then i don't mind splitting or
going halfway you know so i have a
question um are you a virgin
no no no no okay i just i would assume
not just you know but
i don't know so do you do you feel like
it's it's fair that we require
traditional like the man paying when
we're not traditional women because
we're not virgins anymore
um
that's a tough question
but you have to try before you buy no
[Music]
are you going are you going to go all
the way in without knowing where you're
getting yourself they used to they used
to and then they're all unhappy with
like 10 kids and just staying at home
taking care of the children not really
the divorce rate's higher now yeah now
because women want more
we demand more mm-hmm
yeah but but
yeah but are we worth more hell yeah
really yeah especially now because women
are so independent you know that's why i
think our value is way higher i think
our value is lower than ever before in
all of human history yeah we're like the
lowest value women possible on the
planet because men men value purity and
youth so the average age of first
marriage in the uk is 31 that's not
young and by 31 how many bodies you got
so so it's not offering to the things
that men value
so it's like how can we say it's like
you're requiring a a higher price for a
used product
not used experienced
because are you really gonna get into a
relationship or a situation with someone
who doesn't have the experience or the
tools
to maybe
you know um make you a better person or
help you learn new things like we're
here to help each other so
see i think you've got to bring
something to the table yeah but i think
that's a very feminine mindset because
like in your head
as women i think we like project our
mindset onto men sometimes
and so
and so like from a woman's point of view
you do want a guy that's experienced and
that you can learn from but like from a
man's point of view they prefer men
there are women that are more pure
yeah but that's not fair then you want
to be showered and babied and taken care
of like i'm your mother so
maybe maybe the men you pick you know
but that's not that's not all men though
i feel like all men have that sense of
like being they want to be taken care of
to a certain extent i think they want
someone that's like kind and nurturing i
would agree with you but they also want
a lot of similar qualities like their
mother
i mean i think they want someone that
would raise the kids so like they want
someone with motherly qualities because
they if they want a wife they need
someone to raise the kids
but like a guy that's worth a damn he
can take care of himself
it unless you're dating like bombs
do you actually believe that guys like
go for people who are like their mothers
yeah to a certain extent because i feel
like similar qualities like so so i'm
probably a rare case right i grew up
with just a single dad so no mama at all
so it's like i find that like statement
like
a bit weird for me personally obviously
because i don't know what like but did
you have any like female role models in
your life nope but i had my brother my
dad that's it so that's all yeah that's
it and my dad did the cooking ironing
worked every day did everything
wow yeah i guess i mean we're not all
the same you know yeah yeah i mean
usually we're speaking in general terms
though right well and if you if you if
we're gonna compare apples and oranges
oranges kids that come from single
father out homes tend to have better
outcomes than people that come from
single mother home so you could argue
that like
women or men take care of themselves
better than women because like women we
have more debt we even though we make
less money
yeah yeah i think you're right because
when my when my parents divorced it was
like the reason why i went with my dad
was because he was financially stable
yeah but my mother wasn't so we that is
better for the kid in in at the end of
the day unless like you know your mom's
going to marry a rich dude or something
like that i i don't know i feel like i
don't know with raising kids finance yes
is helpful but then your morals
are the most important because one
person can have a lot of money but if
they have no morals
and no decorum no no sense of like
acting like a person then your child is
all ready can they learn that from their
dad though why does it have to just no i
never said that it hasn't been from the
mum but i'm just saying even if they
have the finances doesn't mean that that
child is going to end up good or in a
good place
no no you're correct but even even so
it's like this the kid that's in a
single mother home is more at a
statistical disadvantage than a single
father home like he's more likely to
drop out of school more likely to go to
prison more like all the statistical
disadvantages that you have like tend to
be from single mother homes as opposed
to that is that more males or females or
both what do you mean like the child is
a male or female or both uh well by and
large like men tend to be more
aggressive i mean um
as like a whole like they're more
disagreeable so they tend to go to jail
more so i would guess it's probably more
men okay
um so what about you guys do you think
what is the bare minimum that you feel
like is required from a female i'll let
drew
thanks
somebody who's honest
and
forthright
i think communication is
the most important thing in a
relationship
absolute
trust
you know and trust is based on
communication understanding
understanding each other
um
so that's what that's
what i've always looked for first and
foremost
to be honest i mean well i mean you know
obviously there are phys physical
elements to start off with but
but then
you know that only lasts so long and
after that it really is about trust and
communication or communication and
building trust what about like cooking
cleaning do you feel like that's a bare
minimum from someone you would take
seriously
like if you're if you're paying for 100
of the dates let's just say in the early
stages
what would you require from the woman
that's a good interesting point i mean i
i'm personally i'm
independent enough to be able to cook
and
and all of that kind of thing but um
i think that if a woman
isn't able to do that it's a kind of a
bit of a negative thing really if she's
not able to do that kind of thing
and
you know in a lot of instances
they make a virtue of not being able to
cook not being able to clean not wanting
to clean up
it's like sorry that isn't a virtue not
for me as far as i'm concerned i don't
expect you to do it
but if you don't do it then
sorry what do you do
so
um if so if you're dating someone early
stages what do you expect from her
like just like we talk to the women and
they say i expect him to pay early on
like what do you expect i think um
i think things have changed
very recently as far as as far as uh
expecting
you know
to be taken to novikov and uh
and
you know that kind of thing that's
that's very very new
you know i mean uh
you know i grew up during the 60s and
70s and sure as hell didn't do that kind
of stuff i think it was all 50 50. it
was all going dutch that's what they
called it
um and that's only changed very recently
um
so
no i you know if
if a young lady was to um
to
uh
expect me to pay
then
that wouldn't come as a big surprise to
me but it wouldn't be a positive
it wouldn't be a positive sign so so for
for me with the paying side of things
usually i will pay anyway like usually
but what i actually want like this is
how i kind of judge it is for the woman
to at least offer or at least offer to
pay half right she doesn't actually have
to pay half
but it's just kind of like a respect
thing like she would just be like no
i'll pay half and and she doesn't have
to you can just then say no no don't
worry i'll deal with it and that's fine
but it's just like i'd like her to do
that yeah in in terms of what i look for
yeah it's 100 physical first um but
after that i actually look at for
education but not in terms of like
academic what i mean is just like
educated in manners educated in in life
educated and like i really couldn't deal
with someone who's just like uneducated
about just how the world works or how
things things actually are so that's a
big like a huge turnout for me yeah
that's that is a very good point what
about what about like what do you
require that she do if you're taking her
out on dates and courting her
um i mean for me honestly it's just like
having a good time or be up for for
doing things right if i want to do
things i want her to also want to do do
those do those things with me um i don't
actually require personally like someone
to cook or clean like i am married and
my wife does does do those things she
didn't before so like she had never
cooked before she didn't clean around
the house she was just an english
teacher and the fact was when when we
lived live together she just started
doing those things naturally so it's
kind of the same thing like she she just
decided okay i'm gonna help you out i'm
gonna gonna do these things for you
so why do you think women complain more
about settling when we require more from
men
we can just exist
where men have to actually bring
something to the table and do things
because they're never satisfied go ahead
speaking to the mic story because
they're never satisfied
i mean it's in the nature of women not
to be satisfied
and so
uh
so any uh
anyone that they choose to eventually
end up with they will consider that to
be settling
i i think maybe they're just always
trying to aim higher like
that's the same it's like and yeah like
like i said
yeah but but like i is is the
unrealistic thing right because i do
have a different experience my wife is
from china which which have more
traditional values like try get married
early things like that yeah um
and and they just don't like do the
instagram stuff don't do tinder really
like some do like i can't speak for the
whole whole of that but yeah it's just
the tinder and like instagram world has
changed the whole like
view of everything i feel like what do
you guys think